cheers
um as most people have said thank you
very much for having me um i love berlin
every time i come here i think about why
i haven't been here in so long and maybe
i should just even move here it's that
great so thanks um so as i said i'm
patrick hammond you can catch me at
twitter
patrick hammond and i'm here to talk to
you today about css and the critical
path now what does that actually mean
and
is it even related to css about css conf
so hopefully all will be explained um
over the next 30 minutes so if you
haven't guessed already i work for the
guardian um
uk liberal newspaper but we're now an
international media organization with
three editions three offices across the
world and
over the last 18 months i've been a
senior engineer on the next generation
project where we've been building the
next generation of the guardian website
completely from scratch
a new responsive website that currently
we're delivering to mobile devices and
hopefully coming to a desktop near you
very soon and as brad frost once coined
the phrase of
we're using a technique that we like to
call planting the responsive seed so
other large organizations like the bbc
and ourselves you know when you turn
around to your stakeholders and you say
right we're going to completely chuck
away the whole entire code base and
rewrite it from scratch how are you okay
with that and you know it's very
daunting for them so we actually used
our mdot sub domain as a testing bed for
this you know new mobile first and
responsive um techniques and then we
last year we moved that over to the www
domain we kind of do a bit of ua
sniffing and we're serving all devices
up to around seven inches um and then as
i said hopefully this autumn we're going
to turn off the entire old platform and
be serving all devices um on the new
platform so today i'm here to talk to
you about some of the lessons we've
learned on being able to make this site
load as fast as possible and how your
css is completely intertwined with that
um
in march of this year we broke a new
record at the guardian where we had 100
million users and last month we broke
that even more of 105 million and i'm
very proud of the the company and the
team and how this is just an
onward-going trend but the current
platform that the guardian that you know
and love was not designed to cater for
this amount of people and more
importantly we now see over six to seven
thousand uniquely different devices
accessing the platform every single
month
again the platform was just not designed
to cater for this all these different
screen sizes browsers
features you know it's just a
combination that you could we just
couldn't have imagined 10 years ago
our platform wasn't designed for it we
needed a better solution
and more importantly the old system has
become a monolith over the years
features bolted on and on on top of it
and
we we knew this and our customers were
telling us this the platform was slow
incredibly slow and so here's an example
on the right hand side is the new site
on the left hand side is the old site
and and this is actually how a user
perceives the loading of our page
and so you see in under a second the new
page renders and it finishes in five it
used to be three but then adverts come
along and ruin everything
and the old site is still crunching
along crunching along the median average
for the old site to load is 12
seconds
that is not acceptable
but it's not just the guardian's problem
this was taken literally this morning i
ran a query using the http archive.org
data on google bigquery and asked it
what is the median what is the average
speed index of our website today taken
from the top 10 000 alexa websites and
this is shocking that the median average
bill lasers um is
nine the 90th percentile is way over
15 seconds and the immediate average
medium is nine seconds it's not just our
problem this is collectively a problem
of every single web developer in this
room the web is slowing down and we need
to do something about it
and we know now from studies that use
users also want their web pages to load
fast and in uh the year 2000 the average
user expected your web page to load
within 12 seconds now in 2013 they
expect it to load under two
and so
like any um
any of you would do when you go out and
build a new product we went and surveyed
our users and asked them about 17 of our
key product drivers and they rated
speed as the second most important
factor to their product
only after easy to find content and you
would hope that on a news website the
content was easy to find so our users
really really do care and this was
actually unsurprising to me that they
they rated speed so importantly but it
came as quite a surprise to our
stakeholders but the great thing for me
is that then that allowed me to use it
as a leverage to so we could invest in
speed when we were building this new
product
and um
nicole did a great job at talking about
jacob nelson's research around this and
about actually user perception so this
this um is research hci research taken
from illegal growth uh very amazing book
called high performance browser
networking which i strongly advise you
all to go and read but um again nico
nicole's already covered this but for a
user to feel like a machine is working
you need to get a response within a
thousand
milliseconds
and after 10 seconds after one second
there's a mental context switch but
after 10 seconds the task is abandoned
you know so this this might not just be
we can't we don't just have to relate
this to websites you could i could be
sitting at home on my sofa changing the
channel on tv i need that machine to
respond to my inter input within a
thousand milliseconds or else i'll have
a context switch again so you're you're
searching on the internet you click a
link you need that website to render
within a thousand milliseconds and so
that's what i'm here to talk to you to
about today
no longer as web developers can we be
thinking in seconds we have to be
thinking in milliseconds
and
we started to think at the guardian you
know what and like most a lot of other
people have done tim cadle has been a
good proponent of this recently of what
if we were to set ourselves a budget for
every new feature that we built in this
website we could had to enforce that
every page
must render within a thousand
milliseconds
how can you start
baking this into your development
workflow setting ourselves a rendering
budget
and that's exactly what we did but i
need to take a step back now we need to
actually for us to be able to do that we
now have to have an understanding how
browsers actually go about painting to
the screen what is the path in which
they take from you clicking on that link
to painting on the screen so we need to
go and actually understand a bit about
the browser internals and i strongly
believe that us as web developers
knowing
how browsers internally work help us
make better decisions in in every day
that we we go about engineering
so that starts with obviously a network
request hopefully you've all seen one of
these before it's a segment taken from a
waterfall uh in web page test we had the
dns look up that's
transforming that lovely human readable
domain string into
an ip address we then have to do the tcp
connection a freeway handshake incurring
maybe multiple round trips there but
once we've got that socket connection we
can then actually perform the http
request like get i want to get that
index file and then eventually that's
alternative fight and eventually we can
then download the content and so all of
this if we start to think about this in
relation to our budget
um this is taken from great resource on
google pastebooks insights and on a uk
average 3g connection i presume it's
probably definitely the same here in
germany 600 milliseconds of that of your
budget is already taken up by latency
latency is the biggest
killer to performance and so
i have no control over that and on a 2g
connection is probably even more it's in
seconds and our budget's just gone so
that only leaves us with 400
milliseconds to play with really
um
so again let's have a look dive deep
further this is quite a simplistic
overview of the the path at which most
browsers will take they all differ
slightly but most of them generic uh it
can be boiled down to this of the path
that they have to take from clicking on
a link to painting to your screen so
we've already seen what the networking
is there incurring the 600 milliseconds
um
we finally have a html file now one of
the beautiful things about html is that
it can be parsed incrementally and we
can build the dom incrementally as we
pass the file and as the bytes come in
and so we're parsing that we're building
a dom like structure um but we have to
stop as soon as the browser finds a
script element or a link element linking
to your style sheet it has to block
render it cannot carry on with parsing
and executing the dom it has a stop go
back and perform that networking again
again incurring that 600 millisecond
barrier so we've already just by having
our html and css have already blasted
for our budget
once we have the css file um and once we
have all of it that's very important to
stress here that browsers can't do
partial uh parsing or rendering of css
because of the nature of the cascade if
it started rendering stuff they found
here styles later on in the cascade
might overwrite them and you get this
horrible mess of reflowing and so quite
rightly the specification says we have
to have the full file before we can
parse and execute it
so once we've got that we can create
what's the often forgotten css object
model and so it's
just like the dom it's a tree-like
structure but containing all of the
style node informations relating to
nodes and the dom
but we've forgotten someone
our lovely friend info javascript
he is tightly interweaned and tightly
coupled with these two object models
these two trees the dom and the css
object model dom construction cannot
proceed until javascript one has been
passed but most importantly has been
executed because unfortunately they're
great features of javascript that we
know and all love like document.write
javascript can manipulate the dom it can
ask the dom it can change the dom
but
there's another type coupling here that
javascript cannot execute until the css
object model is available obviously
because if javascript queries the dom
for a style on one of those nodes we
have to have that information so
javascript blocks rendering of the dom
it blocks
dom construction but it has to wait
until css is ready so it's is horrible
intertwining and that is why we have the
age-old best practice of your javascript
at the bottom and declaring it
asynchronous or deferring it making a
promise with the browser that it's not
going to alter anything it's naughty you
can perform the networking for this
whenever you want i don't care it's not
critical to my rendering
and that's
trying to start beginning stressing the
point here css really is the only thing
once you've declared javascript as
asynchronous css should be the only
critical thing to rent painting to the
screen and once we have that information
we can construct the browser can
construct a render tree and now a render
tree again is another tree like
structure
containing all the information from top
left to right to down and but it will
only contain the information required to
paint to the screen so if the css object
model says that a div is display none
that div will not make its way into the
render tree it's only the information
that we need once we've got the render
tree the browser can then perform
layouts i.e calculating the geometry of
every element and its positioning on the
page and this is where you might well
have known seen in your favorite
developer tools that you'll see we've
now got timing information for layout or
also known as reflow after the page and
so every amendment to the dom you make
you're causing the browser to reflow
you're causing it to re-calculate all
the geometrics on on the page and
finally we can then paint to the screen
and so let's have a look at this in a
different in a different way and seeing
actually how this path is constructed as
we're saying we're we're requesting a
page and this is our render process on
the top we get the html file we get the
response and all the time we're blocking
rendering this is just idle that process
blocking rendering blocking rendering
incurring the cs the the depth
networking again we've declared our
javascript as asynchronous so actually
that can be run afterwards finally we
can render the page here
and this is your critical rendering path
the css is the only thing that should be
on it
and so we have a look at that again back
at our waterfall because we've declared
the javascript as asynchronous we're
waiting for css to block and eventually
here's our start render event
we must get the css down
as soon
as possible
in my opinion
it is the critical path
hopefully you might begin to start think
where i'm going here with this how can
we optimize css for this critical
rendering pass
but then when you start to think about a
responsive website what actually is your
critical css what is your css the only
the minimum amount of css that you need
to render your core content the content
that your user came here for but
unfortunately you know in a responsive
world that concept of above the fold is
a very tricky thing
it's a hard problem and so
what's
is it what is your critical css is it
your sharing widget is it the popular
content module is it your comments or
your related content or you're
definitely not your commercial
components no none of this is critical
to the page it's not what the user came
here for my users came to read the news
and therefore the only css that should
really block my rendering
is the article itself and maybe the
navigation at the top as well that is
the only critical css on my page
and so we've taken this notion quite far
at the guardian that in fact we have a
rule that we don't even allow any of
those components to block rendering so
we actually send only the h
in the initial payload the only html
that gets sent down to the document is
the article itself and then we
progressively enhance the page via
javascript and loading in the css for
that later
and so what we're left here which is
very streamlined
critical content
so
what if we were to in line that critical
css into the top of our document
the browser
wouldn't have to perform that 600
milliseconds overhead again it will have
all of the information it needs within
one single htc http request and so it
could instantly paint your critical
content
so that's exactly what we started to do
at the guardian
but it goes against everything that we
have been taught as front end developers
separation of concerns your css your
styles in your style sheets your
behavior and your javascript
you know it's html shouldn't really have
like the pure nature of the stack
shouldn't have um presentational data
inside it it's just for machines to read
it goes against everything the first
time i saw this i was like what the
but actually
you'll see in a second why it's so
important so if you go to our beta site
now and you literally inspect the source
you'll find a dirty great block of css
right at the top of our page now it's
important to note here something that i
didn't mention earlier on in the
networking is that obviously it could be
detrimental if you were to put the
entire styles in your document in fact
you'd you'd cause your your content
download to be longer than the initial
paint and it's also got caching issues
with it as well so we have to limit this
block of information to 14 kilobytes and
the reason why that is if some of you
know about tcp tcp has a great feature
called slow start and it means that the
initial connect congestion window for a
tcp socket has to start off small and
that can if your server is set up
correctly the congestion window will 10
so it's 10 the first 10 packets and
first 10 packets equates normally to
around 14 to 16k so if you want to get
all of the information required to
render your style sheets in the first
round trip so not incurring any more
latency you have to limit that to 14k
you can start to see how tricky this
starts to get you know your critical css
needs to be within 14 kilobytes nothing
else can block that but then
it's magic your browser has all the
information it needs and so
again what does what is this how how
does our users actually perceive this so
on the top here we've got our website um
loading without inline css and the
bottom with
i freight um i apologize for the
person's uh face in this
i mean that's a british joke
sorry the um
so
what you'll see here though is that the
with inline css we rendered way within
our budget 600 milliseconds
and then afterwards you know we
miles miles ahead we've nearly finished
rendering the entire page and that one
hasn't even started
but the observant people in the room
would have noticed well you know you've
only got 14k of css here
where's the rest of it coming in and you
can't block you can't it's because css
is a blocking resource we have to hide
it from the browser and essentially by
doing that we have to load it
asynchronous so at the bottom of the
page we've got javascript function that
if we deem the browser to be a modern
browser then we load it with an ajax
request if the response from that was
200 and then we can inline it in the
document and maybe cache it which we'll
talk about a bit and if it's not we'll
just load it with a traditional link tag
and be done with it
so you'll notice that i mentioned the
caching of this because again the more
observant in the room hang on a second
you know you're loading it
asynchronously your browser's already
painted but surely you're going to cause
another massive reflow when the new
stuff comes in and actually again that's
going to be detrimental to your users
and that when we first started using
this technique we didn't uh do any form
of caching and with every paint we got
this yes it loaded and it rendered fast
and i was like look how fast our site
loads but then the creative director of
the guardian came in to my office and
was like what is this double flash on my
website you know i that's not what that
i designed and he he was right and we
started to think about this how can we
avoid the second the second reflow the
second paint
and so how we solve that is we
after we've asynchronously loaded in the
javascript we can then cache it in local
storage so again is it a modern browser
if it's not
this request with a link can be done
with it
if so
have is this a subsequent request do we
already have css in the cache brilliant
if so let's paint and so now we have all
of the styles to render the
entireguardian.com
within the single http request
if it's not
do we have local storage space if so
let's request it in ajax push it into
local storage and then eject it ahead so
the subsequent request rounds we've got
um and here it is and we so
we um
we also have to do a bit of caching
validation here so we use an md5 hash of
the css file
and use that as the key inside local
storage so the next time around we we
know what the latest key is we loop over
all the objects inside local storage if
it's a new one we nuke whatever is in
local storage so just a simple caching
validation and inject the new styles for
the next time
um really a massive gotcha that we had
local storage if you can't write to it
will throw and actually throw a runtime
error and we had to we learned that the
hard way um so always wrap your storage
rights in a try catch
and then in the head of the document
as i said we on all subsequent requests
we check if it's there instantly inject
it in
all styles within the first http request
and so when i i've been talking to
people about this technique and a lot of
people ask us about how do we go about
actually deeming what is the critical
css and
ad is actually going to do a great job
at talking after me about how you can
automate this process but unfortunately
we try to automate it a lot but with the
sheer amount of modules and styles we
have the guardian um we actually found
that manually crafting these these files
is a lot easier and we it gives us a lot
fine-grained control right over an
automated process that doesn't take into
consideration um javascript or adverts
so we have a we have a set of five head
files that we manually craft
benefiting from css pro processors like
sas that we can just inc this is our
default one we can only and you'll
notice here as i mentioned the critical
content just the article is the stuff
that we we're in lining into the page
and then we just have a simple uh
i o string read and write reads from the
file writes it into the server's
response
but so we've seen what that perception
is to the user what about the data
behind this so this is what our website
um loaded like before i mean it's a good
shaped waterfall that's what your
most default website should look like
but you know we're blocking again on our
start render event here
and so once we've inlined it look at the
note the location of that from before
so because we've declared this
asynchronous the browser's had all the
information there and it doesn't it can
start render instantly it doesn't care
about those other files and so we've
managed to save 500 to 600 depending on
the conditions of milliseconds off our
start render event
most importantly breaking our thousand
millisecond budget breaking the news to
the user as soon as possible
um so if you literally go open up your
dev tools now go to theguardian.com
you'll notice that there are no style
sheets loaded into the page and you'll
if you go and inspect your local storage
you'll you'll see our css there global
css file and um
as jed mentioned earlier we also have
taken this one step further and started
doing it with
our fonts as well
and i really wanted to include this
slide because i i'm
my friend tom that works at the
government digital service and this uh
brad wright one of their other engineers
there said something that really really
rings home to me and that all of this is
just
new forms of progression enhancement
but what a lot of people when they've
been talking about this technique
recently is that they focus on the the
performance perceived performance impact
it gives and yes that's great it does
give users perceived performance impact
but more importantly
it makes you start to create resilient
websites websites that are resilient to
failure websites that don't care about
the networking stack and i can if i'm on
the train i can see a tweet i could
click on it click on the link
and i go into a tunnel now with a
traditional website i might i've made
the initial http request for the index
file but then i'm now in the tunnel my
browser sitting there waiting on the
network to download the css file but on
the guardian i can go into that tunnel
and my browser has all the information
it needs
you're creating sites that are resilient
to failure
now
again when i talk to people about this a
lot of people ask me
why don't we use cookies to do this and
so there's an interesting story behind
this that actually this technique isn't
actually that of a new technique and
steve saudis wrote a blog blog post way
back in 2011 um where he started to
notice that the google and bing search
pages
well actually google
sent down the entire styles for even
though i said that was a very bad
practice earlier on the entire style was
for their page in the first http request
but then they set a cookie
and then on subsequent requests they
check if that cookie's there and then
they don't send down any styles at all
because they know that you've got them
cached in local storage
so making extremely light pages and bing
we're doing exactly the same so the
reason why we don't do that is that we
we've got quite strict edge caching
rules so that we can cache everything on
the cdn on the edge that we try not to
have any cookie logic at all so we've
opted not to use that but i strongly
advise you
if you do want to play with this
technique to use this
so you get the initial request you
inline the css
um you can then render the page store go
and fetch the rest of it store it in
local storage and then drop a cookie and
then on all subsequent requests you can
check to see if that cookie's there
and then render
the response with default links it might
be cache or none at all
and then instantly render all of the
information
now with all um performance techniques
you must measure
optimize and repeat okay the foundation
of every solid performance strategy is
good measurement and instrumentation and
you know your websites will slow down
promise me ours does all the time it's
the nature of the internet it's the
nature of developing software so you
have to keep a monitor on this
and so
one of the things i found the most
annoying using this technique is that
you this concept of what is critical
content what is the css that i need in
critical heads and so i found this
problem a lot that i'd go onto github
and i'd find one of my other colleagues
including the new module in there in the
default head file and it's just warning
bells to me like hang on a second and i
then have to start a conversation and
github going you know is this really a
critical component you know is it above
the fold no i don't think it is what is
it doing here you know the minus plus
thumbs down ad
and so i started thinking myself how am
i going to solve this problem you know
i'm getting fed up of having to
start being mean to my colleagues so i
wrote a grunt task called grant asset
monitor that we monitor every single in
our ci build i'm monitoring all of the
uh sizes of our javascript and css files
and so i can trend them over time but
more importantly i can set thresholds
for that 14kb limit and so i will get an
email
from my ci server telling me that
some code that a developer has just
checked in has just broken one of our
performance budgets and then i can go
and you know poke them and say can you
sort this out please
um
and so it's all well and good having
real-time data like that but we also
need uh synthetic data as well as for
long-term trend analysis so there's a
lot of tools out there we chose to use
one called speed curve and you'll see
here so i'm monitoring against all of
our even our own old site our new site
and our competitors the start render
event here and you can see that our
trend we're staying but within our
thousand millisecond budget but the
great thing about tools like this is
that then they can get exposed to the
business we get an email every monday
morning that's gets sent to the whole
team not just the engineers so i can now
start to instill this performance
culture in our project managers our
designers as well so when we have a
change that's a breaking change we might
have not noticed it the week before and
my pm can now come and poke me and say
hey what happened to the site last week
why have we why have we increased our
load time by 10 seconds
you need to be able to instill that you
can't just be you as a developer doing
this performance is everyone's problem
and it's the designer's problem all the
way up to your project manager
stakeholders everyone must be involved
and care about the speed of your site
now uh when i was planning this to hook
i uh chrissy and michael were like yeah
can you really like involve some of the
tooling and fortunately uh addy came
along to me last week and was like hey
i'm going to do a whole section on
tooling and so i was like yes i don't
have to do the tooling bit of it and
actually is in much better hands than me
because adi wrote most of these tools
that are here so um he's going to go and
talk about this later but just you know
you don't have to do it manually and if
you just want to try it out on a new
project today there's a whole wide range
of tools that are being developed around
this um pagespeed can do it on the fly
for you adi's critical basket js
squats load css but as i say adi is
going to cover all of that now one thing
that might i hope is going through your
mind right now is but surely this is a
hack
you know why should we be having to to
trick the browser like this this can't
be right you know this it goes against
all of our best practices and i agree
with you
and hope uh fortunately there's a lot
been done about it
so the first one is the resource
priorities api
and so one thing about lazy loading your
your style sheets asynchrony at the
bottom of the page is that browsers have
a great feature called the look-ahead
password the pre-parser and what that
does is it speculatively goes ahead
whilst the dongle is being constructed
and finds all the script tags and the
link elements and actually starts
performing the networking behind and so
by removing those stylesheet link
elements from the page you're actually
doing a detriment to the pre-parser
because it can't find them and so
actually it is again a hack but
fortunately the resource priorities has
come up with a new attribute called lazy
load that we can apply to videos images
and
in this case for link elements and
just like async can defer on script tags
you're making a promise to the browser
saying you i don't care about the css
actually you know it might be for an
animation that's after a button has been
clicked and so um you can perform the
networking for it whenever you want but
most importantly
either this is not a render blocking
resource you do not need to block
rendering for this resource
and
wouldn't be any performance talk without
mentioning hp2 we're currently all of us
are using hp 1.1 it was uh that was
finalized in 1997. it's shocking how we
haven't had any change
uh transfer protocol of the web for so
long but you know it's actually such a
good spec that we didn't need it but now
this isn't working draft it's going to
be finalized in november and we can all
start using it already today uh with
protocols like speedy um so what this
allows in relation to this technique and
css is that it allows multiple
concurrent connections on the same tc
messaging sorry on the same tcp
connection but more importantly it has a
feature called server push
and so in our traditional model we're
asking this over the html file we get it
back we then parse it i'll write there's
a link element go back to server get
that then we can render and with server
push us as developers know what the
critical assets on our page are so we
can actually when the
when the ua asks the html file it also
says hey
i know you're going to need a css file
straight away after this and this is my
critical css file so send it down at
exactly the same time as the html file
so again over the same tcp connection
we've already got all of the information
it does something quite clever that it
just sends the header down because you
might already have it in your hp cache
i can't wait to be able to use this
feature
um
finally in this section um i really this
is some the web technology that i'm most
excited about and i think it is
literally going to change the way that
we create websites and we think as
developers are creating websites for
good um if you're here for jsconf i
highly recommend going to jake's talk
tomorrow morning about service worker
who's going to go into a lot in a lot
more depth but what essentially what
service worker is is it's a separate
worker process that runs in the
background with your ui thread and um
it's in is essentially a proxy layer
that's intercepting every single network
request for that domain
and you get past that request object in
javascript and you can decide whether or
not how you want to respond to that
either let it go off to the networking
stack or maybe pull it from a new cache
object which are incredible things um
and so we've got our traditional request
here but actually no i don't want to go
to the network i've got this file in my
cache return it instantly and as i was
saying this will start to allow us to
build resilient websites that don't care
about their networking and it's really
going to change the way we do that at
websites we must start thinking in an
offline first world
so before i go i just wanted to
summarize some of the key points that i
tried to make here and if it's anything
you take away from today please let it
be these
um
try to inline your critical css
and most importantly default defer all
other non-critical assets nothing should
be a render blocking resource unless it
is critical to your user
where you can cache aggressively
and always try to set a performance
budget but most importantly measure
optimize and repeat i'd be really
interested if some of you been trying to
set performance budgets as well and like
please come and talk to me afterwards if
you're you're trying out these
techniques um we're developing the whole
platf the whole new site in the open on
github so all of this code all these
examples and you can read a lot of the
documentation and thinking we've got
there so um we'd love to people to help
them contribute and my slides will be up
online there in about five minutes thank
you